den un paso al frente si están de
acuerdo con el enunciado la cultura de
la cancelación es buena
somos libres de opinar lo que queramos
pero todo el mundo puede responder y
cancelar te si dices algo racista
homofóbico y transfóbico al final
cancelar a alguien significa
quitarle la plataforma a una persona que
difunde mensajes de odio que opinan de
que hayan cancelado a trump en twitter
cuando abres una cuenta en twitter y le
das click a acepto las normas de la
comunidad debe seguirla así él no la
siguió twitter tenía el derecho de
eliminar su cuenta muchos sostienen que
twitter está sesgado y que sólo cancelan
a políticos de derecha pero eso no es
cierto twitter y otras redes sociales
han cancelado a activistas de izquierda
yo diría que hay un balance
no estoy de acuerdo con que lo hayan
sacado de twitter como dejan que el
talibán hace redes sociales pero un ex
presidente no en mi opinión eso no está
bien ellos violaron las normas de la
comunidad eso no importa
no importa quién sigue o no sus normas
por eso eliminaron la cuenta de trump
porque él violó las normas de comunidad
así funcionan las plataformas 'tik tok'
youtube instagram sabías que los
talibanes apedrean a los gays si
hubiesen publicado un vídeo haciéndolo
deberían eliminar sus cuentas porque
sabemos que está mal pero se trata son
muy listos como para poder hacer eso sí
porque el presidente no
si debo votar en unas elecciones por una
persona u otra necesito el mismo acceso
a ambos para poder decidir puedes tener
una secta decir que odias a los negros
pero tu opinión no depende de mí no
puedo esperar que todos me amen o
piensen igual que yo todos aquí somos
diferentes y es genial pero no pueden
cancelar a alguien por pensar diferente
no es justo para nadie creen que todavía
existe la libertad de expresión en
estados claro aún hay libertad de
expresión pero no puedes entrar a un
cine y gritar incendio la libertad de
expresión tiene sus límites pero alguien
a quien silenciar y quien puede hablar
si dices algo que está mal la gente
puede reaccionar están en todo si es
cierto por supuesto si boston
eeuu es más inseguro cada día
ustedes empiezan
muchos de mis amigos han sido militares
por 20 años pero por qué no quieren
vacunarse me dijeron que serán
expulsados de las fuerzas armadas siento
que estamos perdiendo soldados buenos
por la situación actual del país a
muchos policías los despidieron y el
crimen está aumentando porque sin ellos
los homicidios están aumentando la
policía vigila ciertos lugares por la
cantidad de crímenes digan lo que
quieran de la policía pero sé que si
estos niños liberales pasan dos semanas
en donde crece su opinión cambiaría por
completo la única ventaja que tenemos
por ser mayores es que hemos superado un
par de amenazas nuestros enemigos como
china y su partido comunista se ríen de
nosotros ahora
rusia debe pensar no debemos hacer nada
lo arruinarán solos y necesitamos que
las nuevas generaciones vean las
verdaderas amenazas y entiendan que lo
que está ocurriendo no está bien
soy mike tengo 59 años y soy un padre
conservador crecer en los 80 tuvo un
gran impacto sobre mí todo mi entorno y
las personas con las que convivía
formaron mi mentalidad
deberíamos encontrar un punto medio y no
ser aún más liberales más bien
deberíamos rescatar aspectos
conservadores de lo contrario veremos
cómo desaparece toda nuestra libertad y
es nuestro deber resguardar la sólo así
nuestros hijos tendrán la oportunidad de
surgir puede acercarse al resto
me hubiese gustado participar en la
sección anterior porque al principio
estaba en desacuerdo con la posición que
tenían pero luego de escucharlos hablar
yo empecé a pensar que en eeuu no
estamos a salvo de los desastres
climáticos inminentes del futuro no
tenemos la infraestructura para
enfrentarlos estoy absolutamente de
acuerdo contigo debemos definir de qué
tipo de seguridad estamos hablando
hablamos del aumento de homicidios luego
de la cob y de otra cosa solo dijo que
se están deshaciendo de la mitad de
nuestros militares y policías la
esclavitud y el holocausto eran legales
y la discriminación que vivimos por el
kobe es legal los que participaron en el
holocausto le hacían caso a hitler
porque era lo correcto en este momento
pierdes tu trabajo si no quieres
vacunarse pero si te vacunas te pueden
controlar saben que estás dispuesto a
hacer lo que ellos digan los enemigos se
acercan pero nadie le importa porque
todos prefieren pensar en sexualidad
orgullo o teorías raciales solo a mi
generación le importa eeuu ese es el
problema
hablar de orientación sexual y todo lo
relacionado hace que el país sea más
insegura o nadie quiere saber con quién
te acuestas no nos importa esperen
volvamos al tema cuando empezó la
pandemia porque nos tomó semanas para
reaccionar como país o desmientan la
crisis de salud pública que nos afectaba
a todos nosotros solo querían deshacerse
de donald trump todo es falso es mi
opinión estoy de acuerdo no creo que
seamos capaces o que los demócratas sean
capaces de crear ese plan hacer que la
comunidad científica fuera de los eeuu y
los otros gobiernos extranjeros se
pongan de su lado solo para poder sacar
a trump del poder me parece una idea
ridícula romper a una piedra en el
zapato que querían eliminar si no
hubiesen votado desde casa les aseguro
que trump seguiría siendo presidente se
los juro estoy seguro la mayoría de los
votos enviados por correo eran para by
dan esa es la verdad exacto no se trató
de un fraude porque votar desde casa es
completamente legal estas elecciones
fueron unas de las más seguras de la
historia hay muchos vídeos de papeletas
falsas esa fue la realidad de las
elecciones que cualquier persona podría
subir eso a tick tock en serio vamos a
considerar como evidencia real es mi
opinión
soy parker tengo 19 años y soy liberal
mis hermanas y yo nos hemos vuelto más
de izquierda y más liberales con el
tiempo que nuestros padres que son un
poco más conservadores antes
cuando era conservador solo me dejaba
llevar por el discurso y toda la
propaganda que escuche cuando era niño
crecí pensando que o no deberíamos
aumentar los impuestos de los ricos
porque eso nos afectaría a todos las
personas no basan sus decisiones en el
sentido de responsabilidad mayormente
las basan en sus entornos las relaciones
con sus padres y sus conocidos y cosas
así mi fuente de noticias es más
confiable que la del otro lado
noticias
cuando leo noticias conservadoras veo
muchas teorías de conspiración que no me
convencen porque si la información
proviene de la opinión personal no la
considero muy confiable creo que solo
tendremos información no sesgada cuando
los medios de comunicación dejen de
darle importancia a crear titulares
llamativos que no son del todo reales
creo que para llegar a eso hay que poner
a las personas sobre el dinero porque
por eso publican lo más llamativo la
veracidad o la utilidad de la noticia no
es rentable para ellos creo que si
pudiéramos centrarnos un poco más en el
bienestar de las personas y no en el
dinero que ganaremos con la noticia
podríamos cambiar ese aspecto de la
sociedad estoy de acuerdo el movimiento
de derechos civiles favorece a los
medios porque es lucrativo si graban a
un policía cuando mal se vuelve
totalmente viral venden camisetas o
carteles es más rentable que mostrarnos
a los dos darnos la mano los medios se
aprovechan económicamente de las
emociones de la sociedad no importa que
opines es mejor que no salgas de tu
hogar porque porque si lo publicas
alguien podría sacarle dinero y no es
justo
los jóvenes de hoy son demasiado
sensibles
lo sabía
me parece bueno que los jóvenes sean
sensibles hace 30 o 40 años no estaba
permitido que fuésemos tan sensibles
crecí con la crisis de berlín y la de
los misiles cubanos no había tiempo para
pensar en nada más porque nos sentíamos
amenazados siempre todos los días pienso
gracias a dios que kennedy lo controlo
los jóvenes vivieron mucho tiempo
mimados no quieren dejar que un hombre
sea un hombre si no dejas a un hombre
ser hombre todo se arruina y la sociedad
se cae a pedazos las familias se separan
un padre es necesario y 36% de los niños
no tienen uno si no hay alguna figura
guiándolos cuidándolos en su vida
piensan tal vez debería ser gay o quizás
trans no saben quiénes son un padre te
da confianza no quiero ofender los pero
los hombres jóvenes son débiles y van a
la guerra no protegerán al país tengo
hoy en día no hay ningún lugar mejor
para ser un hombre negro que eeuu vayan
al medio oriente y digan que son gays y
vean los tratan
soy yo ni tengo 32 años y soy un padre
conservador para mi abuelo no existían
excusas creció con las leyes de jim crow
trabajaba duro la casa que compró sigue
en mi familia tenía un enorme jardín y
si lo arruina baste perseguí a los
hombres que vinieron antes de mí
literalmente hubiesen perdido sus vidas
por pasarse de la raya o no hacer lo que
la sociedad quería lo peor que podría
pasarme es recibir un tweet con insultos
tengo la oportunidad de ser más libre y
sé que puedo crear cosas con mis propias
manos
soy juana tengo 17 años y soy liberal
sólo quiero igualdad para todos y las
políticas liberales actuales se alinean
con mis ideas de buscar igualdad para
personas de la comunidad lgtb y de
género fluido algo que no me gusta de
los padres conservadores es que no les
gusta abrir un poco la mente y no
quieren escuchar a los adolescentes como
yo muchos creen que porque son mayores
saben más pero eso no siempre es cierto
el resto puede acercarse
ambos dijeron que si un hombre es criado
por una mujer es más débil eso en mi
opinión es totalmente falso nuestra
generación no es más sensible somos más
conscientes de todo ser transgénero o
gay no es algo de lo que nadie debería
avergonzarse o que disminuya el valor de
alguien en la sociedad por eso las
mujeres luchamos por igualdad muchos
piensan que si te crías solo una mujer
es débil o demasiado sensible eso en mi
opinión no tiene sentido en donde crecí
los embarazos adolescentes eran de
chicas que no tuvieron padres lo mismo
pasaba con los homicidios las chicas con
padres se casan antes de tener hijos
porque no tienen padres porque muchas
mujeres no eligen bien al hombre con el
que procrean si te equivocaste es tu
responsabilidad todos mis errores los
cometí cuando mi padre estaba preso
cuando salió y volvió a apoyarme me
convertí en alguien mejor es cierto
tengo una hija que tuvo que mudarse
porque debía deshacerse de una relación
tóxica él quería hacerle daño porque una
mujer tiene que mudarse cuando la culpa
en realidad es del hombre porque no les
enseñan valores a ellos es cierto hoy en
día muchas debemos lidiar con cosas así
las mujeres y madres debemos enfrentar
problemas que los hombres no pueden
imaginar no somos más sensibles solo
tenemos más libertad para hacerlo hace
unos 15 ó 20 años no había forma de
publicar vídeos de policías disparando a
hombres negros en internet ahora que es
posible las personas tienen el derecho
de reaccionar y decir su opinión sobre
el tema y crees que también deberían
mostrar a policías interactuar con
hombres blancos porque matan más hombres
blancos que negros si comparas esas dos
estadísticas la cantidad de hombres
blancos siempre será mayor porque son la
mayoría en el país el porcentaje de
hombres negros que son asesinados es
mayor que el de hombres blancos pero si
te detienen no tienes por qué actuar mal
no te detienen para matarte todo depende
de cómo actúes en el momento me han
detenido y nunca ha terminado mal si
eres crucero te sacan del auto es una y
un personal si no asume sus errores
siempre serás un esclavo no es cierto la
policía tiene muchos problemas hay
demasiada presencia policial en
comunidades negras o de personas de
color la vigilancia es más minuciosa en
comunidades negras y los policías
permanecen más horas en estos lugares no
todo depende de los civiles la política
daño a mi relación con un ser querido
es probable que sepas de esto pero en la
comunidad asiática hay discriminación
hacia los negros desde que surgió el
movimiento de black lives matter en 2020
ha sido difícil tener conversaciones con
mis padres parecían no querer ver las
injusticias ni entender la razón de ser
del movimiento no fue nada fácil
hablarles tienen una mentalidad muy
cerrada muchos familiares votaron por
tromba en las elecciones y yo no estaba
de acuerdo no me gusta decirlo pero
entendí que moralmente no somos iguales
y note que no les gusta mucho escuchar
una opinión contraria estaba muy
sorprendida porque en verdad quería
entender su lado y así poder conversar
la única respuesta que me dieron fue
estás equivocada creo que eso afectó la
forma en la que veía a muchos familiares
y estoy de acuerdo esta situación hizo
que quisiera gastar menos energía en
conversaciones políticas o difíciles con
mis padres o cualquier otro miembro de
mi familia
me llamo retweet tengo 18 años y soy
liberal crecí en un hogar inmigrante de
bajos ingresos creo que el sistema que
tenemos ahora no está diseñado para
apoyar a ciudadanos estadounidenses como
mi familia y yo como mis padres son
inmigrantes tienen una mentalidad
liberal en cuanto a la migración o cosas
que los afectan directamente me gustaría
preguntarles a los padres conservadores
por qué no están dispuestos a
adaptar sus creencias ya sean políticas
o sociales luego de tener conversaciones
con sus hijos y porque no son más
flexibles la política dañó mi relación
con un ser querido he leído historias
trágicas de familiares que ya no se
hablan me parece triste todos en mi
familia pensamos igual no
tenemos una idea clara de por quién votó
cada uno sí pero sabemos que estamos de
acuerdo en que no estamos de acuerdo no
dejaré de comprarte un regalo de navidad
porque votas t por alguien que no me
gusta y no tiene sentido las familias
son especiales
y demasiadas personas como mencionaron
no las tienen a lo que me refería antes
es que mi forma de ver a las personas
cambió por muchas razones no por quién
votaron sino por los valores morales que
ellos estaban defendiendo eso es un
reflejo de su personalidad no crees que
los valores morales son subjetivos para
cada persona o piensas que son los
mismos para todos el valor más
importante es la igualdad para todos
porque si crees que alguien no merece lo
mismo que tú debido a su género
orientación sexual su raza u otro motivo
hay un problema al menos esa es mi
opinión ese es el problema con los trans
los gays y esas comunidades crecí mormón
en yuta el 95% de la población también
lo es y bautizan a los 8 años y como el
95% de personas que te rodean piensan
igual eres demasiado joven para ser
consciente de lo que estás haciendo por
eso mi problema con los trans y los
otros grupos es que adoctrinen a los
niños a los 10 o 12 años y los empujan
por ese camino cuáles grupos cuáles
grupos quién adoctrina a los niños para
que se unan a la comunidad lgtb de cv y
etcétera hay muchos grupos cuales he
escuchado que los hay no lo sé no crees
que haya grupos haciéndolo no al ser un
hombre hetero no deberías hablar así de
la experiencia queer y la forma en la
que se siente una persona que se está
descubriendo lo describes como
adoctrinar pero una persona que está
descubriendo su sexualidad de identidad
queer no siempre va a identificarse con
la primera etiqueta que les presenten si
no me equivoco el cerebro se desarrolla
por completo a los 25 correctos
infancias recuerdo cómo era a los 16
cielos recuerdo cómo era a los 21 siglos
los chicos pueden hacer lo que quieran
pero cuando creces cambias me tatué a
los 15 ahora sé que hubiese sido mejor
esperar un poco más los jóvenes no
piensan todos nos hemos equivocado estos
chicos se estresan y cambian de género
porque quieren probar algo nuevo luego
no hay vuelta atrás
todo eso a los niños es adoctrinamiento
porque quieren atraparlos antes de que
sus cerebros estén desarrollados por
completo te vuelves más conservador a
medida que envejece
cuando crecí y tuve hijos y familia
empecé a leer las leyes cambie por
completo porque ahora tenía una razón
para ser mejor sé que estarás de acuerdo
si ahora noto muchas más cosas que antes
siento que quieren cancelar la
constitución y también el cristianismo
que así todos los jóvenes son liberales
y yo lo era su edad es divertido ser
liberal cuando eres joven quieres estar
a la moda pero no hay veces y no hay
tiempo para pensar en lo que dijo lebron
james o cosas así cuando creces valoras
más todo lo que tienes
me llamo song
tengo 36 años y soy un padre conservador
mi padre es casi mi ídolo lo he visto
tener éxito en todo lo que hace y cómo
vive su vida con sencillez gracias a la
palabra y a los principios conservadores
al ser criado como mormón y como
muchos se juzgaban no creo que sea
necesario que todas las personas tengan
una religión pero sí creo en las
oraciones he pasado por muchas cosas a
lo largo de mi vida y ahora debo parte
de mi felicidad valores conservadores
retomando lo que decía vimos todo
diferente porque somos otra generación y
creo que por eso sienten que muchos más
adolescentes somos liberales pero no
tienen nada que ver creo también era
liberar la ciudad al igual que mis
amigos porque cuando eres joven todo es
divertido siempre entiendo lo que es ser
adolescente pero cuando creces puedes
oír de tus responsabilidades o asumir
las todas cuando te enfrentas a la vida
real tu forma de ser cambia antes no
sabía nada de eso no sabía de los
impuestos ni de cuentas de banco no
sabía nada cuando eres joven sabes muy
poco cuando hablamos de aumentar los
impuestos de los ricos estamos hablando
de los 400 multimillonarios que pagan
menos impuestos de los que pagan la
clase media ellos pagan una tasa
impositiva real del 8% y obviamente eso
no es justo creo que todos estamos de
acuerdo en que deberían pagar algo un
poco más justo no es así como le
aumentan los impuestos a los bienes de
alguien porque esos millonarios las
plusvalías no realizadas son una manera
de hacerlo pero lo ideal sería aplicar
los impuestos a las ganancias a largo
plazo porque existen muchísimos vacíos
legales que permiten evadir esos
impuestos grandes empresas y políticos
han aprovechado esos vacíos por años si
trabajas muy duro y ganas mucho dinero
debes pagar más porque otros no trabajan
tan duro como ti pero no porque
trabajaron menos que yo es porque como
sociedad me gustaría que todos tengan
acceso a lo básico como la salud de
educación todos deberían tener igualdad
de oportunidades pero no tenemos eso
ahora puede existir la igualdad de
oportunidades pero los resultados serán
diferentes porque no todos actúan igual
verdad claro no por supuesto así
funciona la sociedad yo logré tener
éxito me gradué de la secundaria con un
promedio terrible y no fui a la
universidad los únicos límites que
tienes están en tu cabeza así es como lo
veo eeuu es el mejor país del mundo
a pesar de todas las dificultades y
problemas si ven al resto del mundo
muchos aún quieren venir aquí puedo
decir lo que quiero y me siento un
individuo totalmente libre un hombre
negro no puede hacer eso en muchos
lugares del mundo hace 3 años el sistema
judicial me quitó parte de mis derechos
y comprobé que la justicia funciona en
nuestro país cuando te despojan de tus
derechos es cuando te das cuenta que
muchos países no gozan la misma libertad
es el mejor país del mundo y creo que lo
seguirá siendo mientras las personas
buenas y justas defiendan lo que es
correcto
me gustaría hacer la pregunta en qué es
mejor eeuu porque es un país que goza de
más libertad en comparación con otros
países del mundo que hay de los lugares
en escandinavia que tienen un porcentaje
mayor de libertad tienen más democracia
tienen mejor calidad de vida mejores
salarios también tienen atención médica
gratuita que es más eficaz y también
mayor acceso a la educación pero todo el
mundo quiere venir aquí no hay millones
de personas intentando entrar
escandinavia porque aquí hay más
oportunidades que en cualquier otro
lugar del mundo no estamos ni un poco
cerca de tener igualdad de género aquí
hay más posibilidad de cambiarlo afuera
es imposible te aseguro que si europa
abriera sus fronteras como nosotros la
misma cantidad de personas que ha
emigrado en masa a eeuu no emigrar y a
europa también iba a hablar de
escandinavia la diferencia es que esos
países son bastante homogéneos tanto en
lo racial y como en lo socioeconómico no
tienen la misma diversidad geográfica
que nosotros mencionó que tenemos la
oportunidad de
y alcanzar la igualdad de género porque
no lo hemos hecho es porque en nuestra
democracia y el congreso están atascados
justo ahora lo han estado desde hace
varias sesiones no hacen nada productivo
aquí tenemos muchas oportunidades y me
alegra no haber nacido en otro lugar
pero no podemos decir eeuu es lo mejor
porque hay tantos países que están mucho
mejor que nosotros como lo hacen como
podemos incorporar todas esas cosas a
nuestro país yo creo que la diversidad
es buena cualquier tipo de diversidad
siempre será útil para todos es muy
fácil encerrarse en una burbuja no
espero que nadie esté de acuerdo conmigo
o se sienta como yo sólo espero que
respetes cómo me siento y yo respetaré
cómo te sientes así es la vida
por supuesto no podría estar más de
acuerdo genial terminamos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]